waschmaschinen sollten ja eigentlich
dafür sorgen dass die wäsche schön
sauber wird doch das ist offensichtlich
nicht immer so wie jetzt ein
forschungsteam aus bonn herausgefunden
hat demnach haben waschmaschinen dazu
beigetragen das in einem deutschen
krankenhaus multiresistente keime auf
babys übertragen worden sind und das
mehrmals und nicht nur das auch in
normalen haushalten können
waschmaschinen echte keine schleudern
sein aber man kann etwas dagegen machen
kriegs um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocken nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen immer wieder
berichten wir hierbei klicks um
science-fiction über multiresistente
keime die von den vereinten nationen
schon seit 2016 als größte und
dringendste gefahr überhaupt bezeichnet
werden derzeit sind es noch 700.000
menschen die pro jahr an infektionen
durch medikamenten resistente keime
sterben 2050 könnten es schon zehn
millionen opfer seien das sagen
zumindest hochrechnung einer britischen
forschungsgruppe voraus das große
problem die größte waffe der modernen
medizin antibiotika sind zum teil
nutzlos bakterien wie die sogenannten
esbl bakterien oder der gefürchtete
krankenhauskeim mrsa sind gegen gängige
medikamente immun übertragen werden
gefährliche keime nicht nur durch den
direkt mensch zu mensch kontakt sondern
auch über verunreinigte gegenstände
beispielsweise über türklinken oder aber
über krankenhaus utensilien im wie
katheter doch auch geräte die fast in
jedem haushalt vorkommen können als
gefährliche keim steudter fungieren
waschmaschinen so passiert es in einem
kinderkrankenhaus irgendwo in
deutschland hier war eine waschmaschine
dafür verantwortlich dass erreger auf
neugeborene übertragen wurden das hat
ein hygiene team der universität bonn
jetzt herausgefunden
die fachleute berichten dass in einem
deutschen kinderkrankenhaus vermehrt
antibiotikaresistente klebsiella oxid
oka festgestellt wurden und zwar auf der
neugeborenenstation die multi
resistenten stämme dieser gramnegativen
bakterien die heißen so können zu
atemwegsinfektionen magen darm infektion
und sogar zu einer sepsis im volksmund
blutvergiftung führen
die erreger sind gegen viele mittel
immun unter anderem auch gegen
sogenannte beta
antibiotika die routinemäßigen hygiene
screenings offenbarten dass immer wieder
neu geborene mit den keimen besiedelt
waren auch intensive
interventionsmaßnahmen bezüglich der
hygiene in diesem krankenhaus waren
erfolglos so wurden dann die fachleute
des instituts für hygiene und
öffentliche gesundheit des
universitätsklinikums bonn eingeschaltet
um diese tragische sache in jedem detail
zu klären weil die gefahr dass dann
kinder eben auch daran sterben war
immens die fachleute machten sich direkt
auf die intensive suche und konnten
sowohl das zuständige pflegepersonal als
auch die brutkästen als quelle der
kontamination ausschließen auch die
eltern der kinder hatten die bakterien
nicht übertragen
zugute kamen den expertinnen und
experten die tatsache dass sich der
erreger als einzigartig herausstellte
dazu die wissenschaftlerin ricarda
schmidt 1000 dieser clip ciena oxid oka
typ war so einzigartig dass er bisher in
dieser form noch nicht in der datenbank
des nationalen referenzzentrums für
gramnegative krankenhauserreger erfasst
war
dies sorgte dafür dass sich der
verbreitungsweg der keime eindeutig
nachvollziehen ließ und so war schnell
klar dass der erreger über kleidung
übertragen worden war
und zwar durch diejenige kleidung die in
einer handelsüblichen waschmaschinen des
krankenhauses gewaschen wurde dazu der
direktor des instituts für hygiene und
öffentliche gesundheit der
universitätskliniken bonn martin exner
der krebszelle oxid oker typ war
eindeutig im spiel fach und am tür gummi
einer waschmaschine im keller
nachzuweisen mit der die handgestrickten
socken und mützen der babys auf der
station gewaschen wurden ein sonderfall
denn normalerweise werden in
krankenhäusern spezielle waschmaschinen
und verfahren angewendet kleidung und
wäsche wird hierbei mit
desinfektionsmitteln und zudem bei hohen
temperaturen gereinigt doch die wäsche
hier also diese selbst gestrickten
sachen wurden in der vergangenheit
längere zeit von einer ganz normalen
handelsüblichen waschmaschine gewaschen
doch nachdem das gerät entfernt worden
war wurden keine weiteren neugeborenen
von keimen besiedelt somit steht
eindeutig fest dass die waschmaschine
die quelle der klebsiella kaymer war
nach ansicht der expertinnen und
experten sind die keime aber
offensichtlich nicht beim eigentlichen
waschen an die kleidung gelangt
vermutlich geschah dies erst beim
finalen spülgang mit kaltem wasser oder
über die wasseransammlung in der
gummidichtung der waschmaschine denn
dort herrschten perfekte bedingungen für
die keime der nachweis darüber dass es
auch durch waschmaschinen seiner
übertragung von antibiotikaresistenten
keimen auf menschen kommen kann ist eine
premiere denn vorherige studien hatten
lediglich dazu berichtet dass sich keime
in diesen geräten einnisten können klar
ist jedenfalls der ganze fall verursacht
gänsehaut glück im unglück dass es sich
bis zu diesem zeitpunkt zu keinen
gefährlichen infektionen bei den
neugeborenen gekommen war die
forschungen haben sich jetzt jedenfalls
bewusst dafür entschieden in diesem fall
öffentlich zu machen dazu die forscherin
ricarda schmidt hausen wir haben uns
entschieden diesen fall aufzuarbeiten um
auf mögliche probleme mit resistenten
bakterien die nun auch weiter in das
häusliche umfeld vordringen aufmerksam
zu machen wenn dieses problem kann nicht
nur in krankenhäusern über leben und tod
entscheiden sondern auch in normalen
haushalten denn immer mehr alte und
schwache menschen werden zu hause
gepflegt auch hier wird die kleidung mit
normalen waschmaschine gereinigt und das
zunehmend auf programmen mit niedrigen
temperaturen
doch die hygiene fachleute aus bonn
warnen dass bei solchen waschgängen
viele bakterien überleben doch vor allem
in haushalten wo pflegebedürftige oder
aber kranke menschen mit infektionen
oder anderen verletzungen leben sollte
die wäsche bei mindestens 60 grad
celsius gewaschen werden die übertragung
gefährlicher keime kann dadurch
minimiert werden die fachleute
appellieren in ihrer studie aber auch an
die hersteller der waschmaschinen das
design der geräte und auch die wasch
prozesse müssten optimiert werden damit
die ansammlung von restwasser vermieten
wird so können auch dem
bakterienwachstum und der kontamination
von kleidung entgegen gewirkt werden wie
wir selber super bakterien züchten
anklicken anschauen und doktor watson
hammer kanal abonnieren bis dann